wird ihnen präsentiert von der leyen für
oliver längert oder weniger lang weg
sind im berner oberland in den
spanischen süden miriam thomas buckley
erfüllen sich den traum vom leben auf
einer pferde fingern auf einer großen
farm im westen kanadas will familie
ruckstuhl endlich ihr glück finden
mit vier tigern wagt re mobiler das
abenteuer er wandert zu seiner freundin
alexandra teetz nach deutschland aus sie
bauen einen tierpark remo müller ist ein
mann mit kühnen träumen
das war schon immer so dank seines
unerschöpflichen einfallsreichtums
konnte er sich schon einige träume
erfüllen
ursprünglich ist es auch sie herr koch
gelernt wenn wir es das bild immer circa
60 sekunden behält den kunst zum zirkus
und so habe ich dann auch gemacht hatten
aber das brauche eigentlich auch fahrer
gefunden wie die hatten die wettbewerb
macht so die kochkunst und wurde ein
dutzend wieder erfolgreich hätte es
natürlich auch viel spaß mache man alles
zu sehen
erfolg bringt macht natürlich mehr spaß
als wenn es nur das ministerium arbeitet
im walter zoo in gossau an winterabenden
verwandelt sich das zu restaurant in ein
varieté mit galadiner als küchenchef
extremo verantwortlich für das wohl von
über 100 gästen der heutigen abend des
trios letzter abend als koch im wald
dazu
[Musik]
die heutige vorstellung
dadurch ganz besonderer moment
ich hielt mich wie jeden dinge dangel
dixie und witz verloren ganz ganz gut
aber danach sieht es ja ganz große frau
kam in eigenen tierpark und danach
treffen sich aktuell mit dem elan
[Applaus]
ein eigener tierpark ist sein großer
lebenstraum und für diesen traum ist er
bereit heimat und vertrautes aufzugeben
einzig und allein seine vier lieblinge
die internet jeden abend geht er bei
ihnen vorbei und schaut ob alles in
ordnung ist
seine vier lieblinge das sind vier
ausgewachsene tiger
[Musik]
den start macht sich usb für die arbeit
zu recht der 47 jährige hat einen
außergewöhnlichen job los steht im
dienst einer schwerreichen
unternehmerfamilie
er kümmert sich um deren häuser und
fahrzeugpark
heute muss er wie ip gäste abholen
[Musik]
doch schicke anzüge und fahrten mit
ps-starken edelkarossen gehören für us
bald der vergangenheit an denn sein herz
schlägt für richtige pferde
[Musik]
580 durchschnittliche wie das pferd
whisper selbst das ganze besonders und
so manche beziehung aufbauen zum verkauf
einer beziehung aufbauen und das ich mir
richtig gut ich habe aus dem bruder
abdullah gül die maschinen immer wichtig
sie gegenüber der harry oder maschine
ist sie aber genauso klein wenig
maschine haben ja also die euro also ich
hab die aliens maschine und nun also der
große schritt es wird künftig
hauptsächlich mit tieren arbeiten mit
pferden er übernimmt eine pferdefarm im
süden spaniens 24 geklärt wurde aber
nicht machen das hormon das hatte bis
jetzt immer aber man sieht das als
elektriker wir wirklich voran
die letzten zehn jahre gemacht habe was
ich vorher gemacht
auf das
[Musik]
zu hause ist teilt sich seine freundin
miriam tormann für ihren arbeitstag
alles muss perfekt sein die hauptstrom
bisher mit dusche liegt alles mit
schminkt und macht schaut wie werde ich
so schnell gewesen jeweils alle gerichte
er ist auch wieder da seid ihr denn für
ihn schon fünf minuten und nach spanien
natürlich einfacher ist es ja klippel
und dann glaubt doch in etwa fünf
minuten
miriam und urs wohnen in einem stadel
welches ihrem arbeitgeber gehört miriam
ist für dieselbe unternehmerfamilie
tätig wie urs sie ist verkäuferin in
einer boutique im dorf kern funk start
die 43 jährige ist in wien aufgewachsen
wegen der arbeitsstelle ist die vor vier
jahren nach gstaad gezogen und der umzug
hat ihr glück gebracht bei der arbeit
lernte sie ihren us kennen
der bentley ist wieder in der garage der
anzug im schrank us repariert jetzt die
heizung aus der alleskönner die perfekte
voraussetzungen für sein neues leben
[Musik]
alexandra und markus ruckstuhl sind mit
ihren kindern unterwegs zum hof der
eltern im thurgauischen egnach auf dem
bauernhof pralles winden ist markus
gross geworden
[Musik]
walter ist der jüngere bruder von marcus
eines tages wird er der chef aufpralles
winken sein
markus arbeitet als zimmermann hilft
dabei in der freizeit auf dem
elterlichen hof mit wann immer es geht
mit dabei die zweieinhalbjährige
josephine
[Applaus]
mutter alexandra ist gelernte landwirtin
christa opa
geräte
auf markus ebenfalls gelernter landwirt
hätte den hof gerne bewirtschaftet doch
der betrieb der eltern wird zu wenig ab
für alle
die schnellladung spaceport bereits in
dieser woche
[Applaus]
das ist mir zu unterstellen wäre gern
wie empore den älteren hof aber bereits
am 8
denn dort hinten in kanada können markus
und alexandra diesen traum leben um ihn
sich auch leisten und dort aber für alle
anderen frankreich und kanada hätten
aber bleiben kosten sind von den ärzten
vor allem land wird belohnt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
noch werden
familie wuchs stuhl steht zum zweiten
mal vor dem großen abenteuer kanada
ihren ersten versuch retten sie
abbrechen müssen
[Musik]
müllers zweiter beruf ist tierpfleger
seine große leidenschaft sind seine vier
tiger die großkatzen stammen aus
verschiedenen zoos die sibirischen tiger
waren zur zucht ungeeignet als
tierpfleger bekam remo die tiere umsonst
er holte sie nach gossau und brachte sie
im wald dazu unter
mit seinen tigern will er nun zu seiner
freundin nach deutschland auswandern
dort wollen sie einen tierpark die tiger
sollen die große attraktion werden wenn
eure füße quadratmeter womit auf den
tieren her
auch wildtiere und das waren immer
andere land möglich sich also im henry
sie glück hat dass man das grundstück
überhaupt funde hin
und das gemeint denn auch täuschen dass
da mache ich das tor abtropfen spruch
habe man lebt nur einmal und ich habe
keine da bliebe jetzt keine guthaben in
die pension da verschwinden wenn
christian doch das leben ist zu kurz und
klein zu denken und schon bald zerteilt
remo rinderhälften im deutschen örtchen
b jedes seiner tiere verschlingt pro tag
zehn kilo fleisch
die rinderhälften stammen vom
nahegelegenen schlachthof während der
zimmer stunde zieht sich remo auf dem
zoogelände in sein körbchen zurück im
moment kostet esche vor einem ort zum
anderen
eigentlich ist der klinik sind wir
eigentlich geplanten habe mir die pläne
halter zum bus messer und hat eigentlich
am meisten sieht vor allem flug jetzt
extrem viele bücher verschlungen
aber das ist sicherlich dass man noch
etwas von dieser witterung und wenn es
auch immer für meine generation war also
ich hab richtig dass der stempel drauf
ist dass man das alles genauso darum
setzten geparkt sei weiter kein ort und
kein mensch ist zu klein um großes zu
planen
[Musik]
usd und hund lobo sind schon früh auf
den beinen
[Musik]
heute hat es einen freien tag und hilft
auf der alb seinen eltern
[Musik]
langsam langsam
krieg und marian baxley sondern auf der
schwarz moosalp im berner oberland über
zwei dutzend kühe auf die unterstützung
ihres sohnes müssen sie schon bald
verzichten
ja das ist gute werbung
[Musik]
bisher waren die besucher auf der alb
eine willkommene abwechslung zur arbeit
in der high society
bald soll ihn dieses schaffen so wie es
ihn seine eltern gelehrt haben wirklich
glücklich machen nicht mit kann von
netzwelt.de das ist viel arbeit aber
diejenigen wir selber sehen rechts für
jedes land befinde zu sechs anderen im
süden spaniens zu dieser zufriedenheit
alltag werden
unten im tal geht seine freundin miriam
tormann reiten
schon als mädchen was sie im pferde
vernarrt
diese leidenschaft hat sie nie mehr
losgelassen
vor kurzem hat ihre freundinnen das
zweite kind zur welt gebracht
miriam und usa haben keine kinder ist
jetzt ein herz mit der richtige partner
darf man keine familie bauer und ja mit
der knete anfang von musik lieben
das fahrzeug habe ihre tage mit dem
geist und auch keine eigenen kinder und
doch eine gemeinsame große
herausforderung ein selbstbestimmtes
leben auf einer pferdefarm mit eigenen
gestüt und reitschule wartet auf miriam
[Musik]
die familie ruckstuhl wohnt in einer
kleinen dachwohnung im thurgauischen
kümmertshausen alexandra und markus
lernten sich während eines praktikums
auf einer farm in der nähe von vancouver
kennen sie verliebten sich zurück in der
schweiz heirateten sie
für die beiden war schon damals klar
irgendwann würden sie zurückkehren nach
kanada 2012 glaubten sie ihr traum geht
in erfüllung
mit einem vertrag als farmarbeiter in
der tasche wanderten sie nach menton bei
calgary aus es war eine glückliche zeit
und genau dorthin wurden sie nun zurück
[Applaus]
häufig kann dieser glaube im märz
alles schien perfekt und die im ersten
jahr brachte alexandra tochter josephine
zur welt doch das glück fand ein
abruptes ende
hoffnungslos überfordert mit allem
kröber und plötzlich ganz krass sie hat
einhalb stunden also sprich steht still
da müssen sie nur geschrei ist die
ganztags schlagseite ärzte
krankenschwester und deshalb die helfer
hätten ja schon mit jörg erhalt
schließlich zu dem rätsel gefunden wieso
das so dass sie so mit zu viel
nachlässigkeit aber sich also ich ja
sagen wir sind also ich persönlich
bedanken
nach untersuchungen im spital bekannt
josephine sliden einen namen das horler
syndrom eine gravierende
stoffwechselkrankheit josef ins körper
war außerstande ein lebenswichtiges
enzym zu produzieren welches
stoffwechselprodukte in den zellen
abbaut nur eine
stammzellentransplantation könne den
tödlichen verlauf der krankheit stoppen
hieß es
beruhigend im mixed
das ist ja es ist der welt zeigt
historische gesundes kind kam
und deshalb teurer und zwar in karow
krank ist und der herrscher nicht immer
eine stammzellentransplantation oder
knochenmarktransplantation wir mussten
wir nenne ich kann spaziergang scheine
für die schwerste ich rief moment dem
sinn gemacht also aber überhaupt organ
oder celle riese vor und es gibt immer
noch sehr viel wo kein spender findet
oder ein infekt sterben schlussendlich
sie hat mehr als halbieren die
medikamente noch okay da ist jeder
infekt aufpreis hebt die eia da macht da
ist ja auch noch nummer mit drin steckt
eigentlich denkt nada zur behandlung von
josephine kehrten alexandra und markus
in die schweiz zurück zurück zu ihren
familien
alexandra war damals zum zweiten mal
schwanger
[Musik]
im walter zoo machen rani timur tanker
und vitali das was sie am liebsten tun
faulenzen renault hingegen ist auf achse
und macht was er noch nie getan hat er
meldet sich in der schweiz ab es ist mir
plant sie zum 23
aber mit dem was man jetzt vor wenn ich
gar keine andere möglichkeit blieb also
so viel land zu dem preis hätte man
jemals über heute schon so ist ein 20
mal mussten überlege was ich nicht wähle
ich sehe das land wo die sprache nicht
kann will das war sehr schwierig werden
für mich war das abenteuer in die
familie die blieben halten da aber es
ist schon immer so
sie bucht wo gegangen ist und wegen der
besuchs probiert bis morgen als so
genannter weißer karriere
doch der wettbewerb ohne haar und wir
haben dann aber entschieden gang zum
zirkus und da sind sich jetzt aber auch
dass abschied nehmen fällt remo nicht
schwer
schließlich wartet in deutschland seine
freundin auf ihn gehabt diesen brief
richtig sehen als letztes mal passt
kommt und jetzt möglich schnell noch
irgendwelche rechnete sinfonie form
auswanderer zahlung ist also wie jetzt
eigentlich ein wo nichts los sagt sieht
jetzt gehabt und darum mache mich spüren
schnell im auto und dass wir dann alles
um jetzt auf verkauft
[Musik]
die müssen wir abmelde
drehmoment nach deutschland haben dieses
land gut so wie ich es nicht aber
[Musik]
miriam steht ein schwieriger abschied
bevor elf jahre lang hatte sie einen
treuen begleiter an ihrer seite den
belgischen schäferhund loben doch logo
kann nicht mit nach spanien
er muss hier in der schweiz bleiben
miriam und us bringen den schäferhund zu
mehr passierbar das rentnerpaar kümmert
sich seit jahren um logo
der elfjährige hund würde die
südspanische hitze nicht mehr ertragen
nun soll er für immer bei mehr
passierbar bleiben
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
in der ostschweiz ist josephine auf dem
weg zum kinderspital
heute hat sie ihre letzte arzt visite in
der schweiz
die vergangenen monate waren für
alexandra und markus nicht einfach und
doch liegt die mutter dankbar zurück
besser machen
jetzt sind extrem taxi und ich tue das
und ich freue mich fordert und extrem pc
und extrem also ich weiß nicht wie wir
schon lange davor klopfen aber er hat
nerven den fels in der brandung vor gut
einem jahr bekannt josephine hier im
kinderspital zürich die lebensnotwendige
stammzellentransplantation ohne eine
transplantation hätten sich in josef ins
organen immer mehr stoffwechselprodukte
abgelagert bis sie nicht mehr richtig
funktioniert hätten
bei einem ultraschall checkt ein art die
herzklappen funktion und ob es
ablagerungen hat
[Musik]
auch im gehirn hätten sich weitere
ablagerungen gebildet mit fatalen folgen
josef in hätte kaum je gehen oder
sprechen können
doch die therapie hat gut angeschlagen
die kleine entwickelt sich bestens und
doch wird die krankheit immer teil ihres
lebens sein
josef ins organe müssen regelmäßig
kontrolliert werden
schwachpunkte bleiben beispielsweise
auch die knochen josef ihn braucht ein
leben lang physiotherapie in dem alter
ist dass es beim eigentlich noch fast
normal wenn die kinder sich aufrichten
haben die ersten roman an kriegen sind
x2 und irgendwann später werden die den
allermeisten und das ist bei ihr
wahrscheinlich nicht sie wird der mix
kleiden
ja das werde ich aber in den weg legen
ihren bericht nach kanada auch nach
englisch das kein problem des ethik
sprach mittlerweile in der medizin
da wird das einschreiben oder dass es im
auge behalten wird und genau die will
über leid dass es in den relativ
freundlich das buch und war mit ihren
werken ich das okay wie dem rechtsgrund
allem das rassische oder spaß und
natürlich klar mit der größe als auch
die kleinen ponys sind dann trotzdem
immer noch nicht groß aber in einleitung
zu reiten ist das ganze leben positiv
also der die möglichkeit hat mit den
kindern zu machen
auf das wachstum des rückens müssen die
eltern im auge behalten
[Musik]
das heißt man sieht fast nichts mehr
aber er ist noch ein bisschen frisch
nicht weg befinde sich aber er ist nicht
rechts sondern ist eher besser geworden
die kurve ist ja du dann wird man nicht
ziehen lassen
ein bisschen schade
[Musik]
hohes patzte ist in spanien angekommen
vorläufig allein merian kommt bald nach
andalusien kennt er von
ferienaufenthalten bestens
dass ich das wirklich fasziniert die je
nach andalusien
nun aber sind es mehr als ferien ein
neuer lebensabschnitt beginnt
es kommt sagte autos hier los angeles
usa die pferde finca zusammen mit einem
schweizer kollegen gepachtet mehr als
die hälfte der 70er der gehört uns seine
investition in das unternehmen
das anwesen mit elf gästezimmern und
stallungen ist 26 hektar groß
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sein geschäftspartner robert alter
erwartet ihn schon aus don roberto nimmt
kurs auf einen rundgang mit
seit zwölf jahren lebt robert in spanien
er hatte bereits einen reithof geführt
auf jedem hof haben sich die beiden
kennengelernt sie freundeten sich an und
beschlossen gemeinsam eine große pferde
finca zu übernehmen
und ich habe dreimal planer kombiniert
3 bietet das haben wir nicht geschafft
[Musik]
die bauernfamilie ruckstuhl
verabschiedet sich im stall kurz aber
nicht ganz schmerzlos
sie sprechen
machst du
[Musik]
da
scheiße
so ist level
ja
adieu paradies finden elterliche hof
radio heimat
[Musik]
halo hat alle formalitäten geregelt aber
die bürokratie war nichts gegen das was
jetzt kommt tiger einpacken
also ich hoffe jetzt dass alle denken
möglichst noch ein name den ich richtig
laufen dann ist das kinderstück packte
aber das wird wahrscheinlich dass sie
also kein zu erfahren dass das sowieso
als willig alles
arbeitskollegen unterstützen remo fast
ein dutzend helfer und ein
professionelles transportunternehmen
braucht es um die vier tiger reisefertig
zu machen
[Musik]
für die raubkatzen ist es bis jetzt noch
ein ganz normaler tag verstehst
kandidaten tv listiger sie das ist die
neugierige siebenjährige tier in rani im
nebenraum bereiten die helfer die erste
transportkiste vor
wirklich dass der ranzen die klemme
wenn das gute so ja doch immer wieder
wenn sie schnellten war das gold das
weich oder nicht für mich ein kleines
stück fleisch soll rami in die kiste
locken
nein
also kinder geschlagen
deine füße eine suppe dichte an diesem
besonderen tag ist auch freundin
alexandra in die schweiz gereist was
alexandra pitz und remo noch nicht
wissen es dauert noch gut drei stunden
bis alle seine großkatzen verpackt und
reisefertig sind
[Musik]
bei familie ruckstuhl ist der abschied
noch nicht ausgestanden
ich hoffe das klappt das machen
vielleicht langweilige am gleichen ort
sind
bis es ihnen langweilig wird dürften
einige jahre vergehen
schon vor dem abflug aber vermissen sie
am liebsten
perfekt und so lange sie dort sind fällt
immer so
[Musik]
familienhund sheep sie darf mit nach
kanada die letzten die verabschiedet
werden sind alexandra schwester und die
grotte von josephine
[Musik]
so
da
[Musik]
tagen nämlich
in der nächsten folge von auf und davon
richtet familie ruckstuhl in kanada ihr
neues zuhause
markus schopp in cowboys tor doch etwas
trägt den schweizer nicht in spanien
versucht um sich mit den pferden
anzufreunden und lebt mit seinem
geschäftspartner die arbeitsbereiche
fest und miriam macht sich sorgen über
ihre künftige aufgabe
[Musik]
im deutschen bell erwarten neugierige
die ankunft der tiger
doch die raubkatzen wollen ihre
transportkisten nicht weil es schlecht
aus
muss ich die kalte füße bekommen
[Musik]
von tina voß wies präsentiert wurde der
leyen für oliver längert oder weniger
lang weg sind